josée legault michel c o j michel david
bonsoir soit la nouvelle ligne de la
journée dans la conférence de presse du
québec c'est le mois d'avril on a réussi
à vaincre les pires elle le mois de mai
c'est le mois de la vaccination
on écoute monsieur le haut je pense que
ça commence à bien regarder pour avoir
un bel été mais la clé évidemment c'est
la vaccination
moi aussi j'aimerais ça qu'on soit
capable d'ouvrir davantage avant même le
75% mais je me dis que si les québécois
on vise à ce que ce sont les 15 % de
chaque groupe d'âge se fassent vacciner
d'ici le mois de juin
on se donne des très bonnes chances de
passer un bel été puis d'avoir des belle
réponse du docteur arruda
si on veut enlever des mesures
sanitaires qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour monter la vaccination alors je le
répète c'est vraiment un équilibre entre
les deux mois de mai mois de vaccination
on va parler ici de l'actif de choses
qui pourront être à l'extérieur
ok faut parler ici d'une population
vaccinée adéquatement faut parler ici de
ne pas être des productions de nouveaux
variants
la question à docteur arruda c'était sur
les terrasses pilar c'est là qu'il a
répondu ça dépend du niveau de
vaccination on est à 38 % au québec
josée legault
en fait le message est clair et
d'ailleurs on vient d'ouvrir sa vient
tout juste de on vient de me le
confirmer le rayon vient d'ouvrir aux 40
ans et plus ça devait être plus tard et
ses deux mains et c'est maintenant
pardon vous pouvez aller prendre rendez
vous quarante ans et plus partout au
québec alors josé c'est le pari que l'on
fait vacciner vous pour vont pouvoir
être plus les bras mais c'est à dire
plus que jamais on est dans cette
fameuse course entre les variants et le
vaccin est long on it encore l'une
demain à la première dose
donc pour la deuxième dose ça nous amène
quand même à moins que ce soit aussi
accéléré au début de l'automne
donc oui absolument et ont depuis les
manifestations de la fin de semaine qui
était vraiment très vraiment désolante
là-dessus mais je pense que peut-être
que ça prendrait non seulement des
points de presse mais même si les
québécois sont favorables
majoritairement la vaccination pour vous
matez selon les experts en tout cas le
pourcentage de population l'accès le
plus haut possible donc au delà des 75
pour ça et on est encore loin de ce
couple mais le mois de mai si vous
voulez de faire rimer le mois de mai
c'est le mois pour ce faire exceller et
on l'a vu aujourd'hui michel cm je
baille dunn qui a fait un appel pressant
afin qu'un ou deux ça va bien ça va vite
mais il a peur au plafonnement aller
dans l'est plusieurs sociétés la part au
plafonnement et c'est ce qu'on veut
pousser comme message public là ce ne
sera pas différent ici d'ailleurs un
moment donné il ya déjà la fin de
semaine dernière mais on appelait on a
connaît on la connaît tous déjà qu'ils
offrent pas su au môle vaccin alors un
moment donné les gens qui sont
convaincus d'avancé que le vaccin ibos
facile d'aller chercher des abonnés au
sein de l'épée puis les faire vacciner
là le problème c'est des autres c'est
d'une part il ya des gens qui sont plus
réticents à votre moitié des gens qui
sont plus difficiles a rejoint une
saucisse important alors un moment donné
vous voyez au saut du lit par exemple
donc on est beaucoup dans les cliniques
mobiles
de vaccination va chercher au marché les
gens peut-être
il va falloir à venir ici mais non on
voit les images est facile déjà fait là
on voit des images à l'auto qui ça va ça
va s'ouvrir très bientôt donc ça
simplifie à l'aéroport trudeau à
montréal donc c'est ce genre d'offre
qu'on devra multiplier où il faudrait
multiplier sans aller dans les quartiers
aussi le monde qui va à l'aéroport mais
le plus difficile commence le facile il
est fait c'est sa chaîne avait on voit
qu'un message a changé d'ailleurs il ya
jusqu'à il ya tout récemment le grand
argument s'était il faut empêcher le
système de santé d'exploser de la style
moins possible maintenant ce qu'on dit
aux gens c'est que vous allez vous faire
vacciner plus on va retrouver la vie
normale rapidement alors il ya une
incitatif parce que pour beaucoup de
monde
bon on voyait les statistiques
d'hospitalisation de soins intensifs
mais tant que vous n'êtes pas l'hôpital
ça demeure quelque chose d'un petit peu
abstrait tandis que la perspective de se
rassembler d'aller au resto seul le
monde comprend soit parfaitement alors
c'est ça s'inscrit aussi dans une dans
une stratégie de communication la ce
message là et au bureau du premier
ministre nettement je vois d'ailleurs le
sourire s'allonger sur le visage de
monsieur legault de semaine en semaine
et on se pince le rang 7 membres mais
comment se fait que ça va si bien alors
ça va si mal ailleurs mais tant mieux
profiter aux usa mais le fait que ça ici
bien comme vous dites jaunes à part à
josé mais le fait qu'ils sont ici bien
ça peut encourager des gens le pro bowl
c'est réglé allons-y josé exactement ce
qu'il allait dire et et il ya aussi le
problème qui reste qui est dans le
système de santé lui-même c'est-à-dire
des employés qui sont en contact direct
avec des personnes vulnérables qui
refusent de se faire vacciner ça c'est
quand même très très grave
lost un problème de santé publique donc
moi je suis favorable à l'obligation la
vaccination d'un pour ces personnes là
mais sinon le passement vaccinale ça
peut être aussi un outil
incitatif très très puissant et et je
parle pas seulement ne passe pas en
vaccinale pour voyager mais pour
justement pouvoir aller une fois qu'on
est vaccinée à deux doses pour aller
dans certains types d'activités faut pas
négliger l'importance que ça pourrait
avoir pour 2002 les collines d'ailleurs
monsieur dubé a dit aujourd'hui
techniquement on me dit que ça va être
assez facile à opérer cette preuve il
parle pas de vaccin mais de preuves
vaccinale alors je vous lance la
question de chasse au gym celle
d'annette jusqu'où il doit aller dans
l'exigence de cette preuve vaccinale est
ce qu'on doit demander ça pour une
terrasse pour 1 au centre bell pour
aller voyager ça tombe sous le sens que
c'est oui mais ailleurs canetti michel
voyager c'est pas voyager c'est parce
que c'est sa voix et une entente
internationale ssi bord est sorti ça ne
montre pas une preuve de vaccination
mais je n'accepterai pas vous ressortir
et vice versa alors elle m'a donné ça va
s'imposer tout seul à l'intérieur du
pays ça c'est complètement autre chose
il ya des dangers de discrimination là
dedans ça va rester quelque chose de
conflit ont dit ça va être si c'est une
feuille de papier c'est la contrefaçon
vont être faciles c'est facile de perdre
son et au travail c'est sur son
téléphone cependant que tout le monde
des téléphones il ya toutes sortes de
difficultés comme ça au sein de la
communauté si vous voulez rentrer ça
risque d'être plus compliqué mais au
centre bell ce monsieur legault en parle
souvent puis d'y penser j'en dis quand
est-ce qu'on pourra aller voir un match
de hockey
michèle dawe est ça pourrait être une
option je parle tant que du centre bell
mais des rassemblements plus important
le vus ailleurs
certainement c'est le moi je vois
souvenir ça assez rapidement l'âge mais
j'ai l'impression j'entendais monsieur
legault aujourd'hui puis voudrait que
demande au centre belge pour les 21000
mais quelques milliers pour les laisser
risée
natoire je pense c'est ça qu'ils
rentrent être comme objectif mais le
vaccin je le verrai bon pour l'avion je
pense est assez nette pour le reste
comme comme quelque chose de temporaire
je pense pas qu'on peut dire regardez le
à partir de maintenant il faut un vaccin
pour rentrer d'un restaurant mais pour
un an ou le temps que la pandémie soit
vraiment vraiment maîtrisé je pense que
ça va s'imposer et je pense que des gens
même par exemple on dit les
restaurateurs voudront pas faire la
police
mais ça leur fait une bonne publicité
sera de dire écoutez vous allez en
sécurité ici les gens qui voient ici ils
voient une vacciner et il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont dire écoutez moi si vos
clients sont pas tous vaccinés j'y vois
pas ça va dans les deux sens là ok mais
le débat va commencer va s'accélérer
après c'est bien très bien
ok vous disiez michel david sourire tout
sourire parce qu'effectivement le la
feuille de route du québec est bien
meilleur que les autres provinces dans
cette troisième vague
marie-eve prouesse que c'est là qu'elle
mesure c'est embêtant on va écouter
monsieur legault qui qui parle de ça
puis on revient en parler on a eu des
informations l'année dernière quéven
creemore de travail qui était difficile
au bureau de marie-eve coup on a
rencontré marie ève proulx on lui
donnait des services et doit au service
30 route de coach et malheureusement on
se rend compte que la situation s'est
pas suffisamment améliorées est-ce que
vous ou votre cabinet avait demandé à
madame proue de démissionner ou est ce
qu'elle a à faire de son propre chef
sans même que personne autour de vent
dans votre entourage prenez initiative
de lui demander
bah disons que tu as d'un commun accord
je pense qu'on a tous compris marie-eve
proulx pour les gens qui se posent la
question qui ne la connaîtraient pas
elles étaient mises et les gains au
développement économique régional elle a
écrit un texte sur sa page facebook on a
un court extrait où elle dit j'ai été
très affecté par les allégations des
derniers jours me concernant il faisant
référence à mon comportement qui aurait
blessé certains des membres de mon
équipe
si c'est le cas je m'en excuse j'ai mes
torts écrit-elle mais je n'ai pas tous
les torts entre royal dit j'accepte de
quitter à leur tour de table michel
david
écoutez cette part ça devenait intenable
c'était une personne ou deux bons il
pourrait y avoir des conflits de
personnalité mais là c'est plus d'une
dizaine de demandes du personnel
demandent à mme proulx qui était parti
dans la dernière année je pense et
monsieur legault la protéger le plus
longtemps possible madame proulx est une
militante que qu'acquise de la première
heure est là parce que sa sortie dans
les journaux il n'y avait plus il y
avait plus le choix
le harcèlement là
pour pas seulement sexuelle c'est
tolérance zéro partout on a vu la
gouverneure générale à ottawa madame
peau je pense que c'est possible pour
monsieur legault à partir du moment où
c'était de notoriété publique
la garder il y aura c'est une femme ça
va poser un problème de parité le matin
un ajustement ministériel justement
remaniement je pense avoir deux c'est
justement quand remaniement mais il est
clair qu'il va falloir qu'une autre
femme accède au cabinet à brève échéance
michel c je pense que quand un bureau
ministériel deviennent endroits où il ya
des portes tournantes sync est quelque
chose qui se passe qui s'est pas correct
et je pense qu'elles qu'elles aient été
informés de cette émission se soit fait
comme une accord c'est très clair que
quand on rentre dans le bureau du
premier ministre parce que ce genre de
problème là on a 100 rarement ministre
surtout quand on lui a donné des choses
quand monsieur les goûters ont rien
donné du coach et on a essayé de l'aider
si ça ne marche toujours pas à la fin
comme disait michel c'est pas acceptable
ce harcèlement dans n'importe quel
milieu et elle chante réseau à
l'assemblée nationale les jeunes ont
quand même donné un peu l'exemple
à partir de ce moment est-ce qu'il y
aurait un remaniement ministériel s'est
passé vous savez il ya quand même des
gens qui performent pas peut-être que je
suis le bon vouloir faire le
désajustement profond comme ça au mois
de juin mais la parité doit il a promis
l'aide de ses promesses et quand il est
aussi qu'on excuse conclusions sur
marjah ont changé mais c'est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui c'était pas une bonne
nouvelle parce que c'est rentrer en
conflit avec le service après vente du
rapport laurent commune et est sûre sur
le fond de la question un an c'est quand
même loin
le bureau du premier ministre a été très
patient certaine cela peut-être trou et
je pense que la réponse vous l'avez dans
le texte même de madame proudhon vous
avez lu un extrait avec beaucoup de
conditionnel avec des si avec et des
excuses qui ne sont que les excuses à
moitié donc ont de toute évidence le
problème est que c'est bon legault et
l'immigration on a parlé beaucoup hier
mais je reviens parce que c'est revenu à
la période des questions on écoute un
échange entre madame anglade et monsieur
legault et on revient puis dans
l'actualité on dit que le premier
ministre a été choqué de voir que ces
propos ont été rendues publiques suite à
une rencontre au conseil du patronat
savait ses rangs mais ce président de
choquer dans une même journée
québec solidaire et le conseil du
patronat en même temps mais monsieur
rémy nice
il a réussi ce tour de force quand on
donne une entrevue qu on fait des
débords avec plus de 100 personnes je te
porte tellement surpris je vais vous
dire de savoir que ça s'est rendu dans
les mains du parti libéral puis votre
demande radio canada je regrette pas ce
que j'ai dit au québec on veut plus
d'immigration économique qui on veut
d'abord créer les postes sont mieux
payés j'ai aucun problème parce que ça
soit répétée incluant par la chaîne le
pousseur ciel je commence avec vous josé
on a l'impression effective sur lagos
assume dit moi je veux moins
d'immigrants est ce que je veux je veux
des immigrants qui vont avoir des
salaires plus élevés jeu loin de
s'excuser et dit c'est ça ma position
oui mais c'est pas la première fois non
plus inquiet qu'il a cette position à la
sauf que ça ça pose deux problèmes entre
autres le premier c'est que
l'immigration
c'est une époque pour ça et il ya plein
de postes aussi qu'ils sont tout à fait
essentiel et honorable et qui payent
moins et qui dont on a besoin on a des
pénuries au québec
et si on ne fait pas appel à la meinau
vecteur qu'est ce qu'on va faire la
deuxième chose et ça c'est pascal bérubé
du parti québécois qui doit soulever
aujourd'hui c'est que critique du
critère de la connaissance de l'en
croire c'est aussi le recrutement être
migrants dont kse que c'est un équilibre
délicat mais comme vous êtes en effet
monsieur legault c'est sûr mais ça ne
veut pas dire que ça pose pas problème
exactement ça vous a imposé que s'impose
pourtant rien d'autant que la deuxième
génération d'immigrants souvent sont
bien davantage payé que la première qui
est arrivé pile à la lok
la première c c mais je dirais que lui a
décidé de s'assumer totalement michel st
oui souvent monsieur legault s'assume
sur des choses ou alors donnant par
exemple il y avait des grains complets
que c'était dans le blanc l'opposition
sur le chef de la réunification
familiale samba ouvert et touche alors
que quand on regarde les chiffres c'est
procopio du tout mais là il se met à dos
toutes les fédérations d'employeurs le
conseil du patronat manufacturier
reporter et ses terres qu'ils disent et
on a besoin d'eux mais depuis son v6
sont pas payés 53 mille dollars
indiquent sans eux c'est pas si mal
quand même
et on a besoin de ces gens là est
rappelons-le l'étang est un employeur
on l'a vu pendant la première vague de
la pandémie quand on en parlait des
anges gardiens de gens qui étaient
souvent 107 sucre qui travaillait dans
les hôpitaux
si on les avait pour lui on a réussi
après problème mais l'état est un
employeur et dans le secteur public dans
des hôpitaux dans toutes sortes d'autres
domaines où le l'état et l'employeur et
il manque de mesdames nous aussi et
l'immigration peu ce qu'on peut être
utilisé pour pour calmer la pression sur
le sol
emploi on revient aux seuils michel
david avant de donner la parole je
rappelle aux gens là qui suit le cette
année à noeux exceptionnellement -
compte tenu de la pandémie 25000
monsieur legault jean peut-être avec 35
le conseil du patronat voudrait au
contraire 70 les libéraux pas très loin
de ça donc c'est ça le débat de fond
finalement une chef
oui mais là je trouve que monsieur
legault à tort tant sur le fond que sur
la forme
il ya une pénurie de main-d'oeuvre là on
dit qui à quoi 130 quelque 1000 places
disponibles et là dessus il y en a
trente deux mille qui sont des postes
payant les 56 mais les plus lentes et
tout le monde veut des emplois payants
la des personnes et compte mais ça se
pose que la laque à les deux tiers des
emplois dont les entreprises ont besoin
c'est des postes qui sont payés moins
cher que ça alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça si on sent des rentes pas ça
veut dire que bon on dit mais tant pis
vous n'êtes pas capable de marcher à
pleine capacité dans votre entreprise
mais on s'en fout nous on veut juste des
gens à 56000 et plus alors là il ya un
problème
et sur le fond la façon dont monsieur de
vaud a dit mot du monde à moins de 5 ans
10050 mon problème
le yahia il ya comme une tonalité un peu
à ces migrants de là dedans puis il ya
quand même encore une fois comme dans le
problème du pecq souvenez le programme
d'expérience québécoise on avait dit que
monsieur de goût manqué d'empathie mais
là je trouve encore qu'il ya un langage
bureaucratique qui manque d'humanité
très avancés sur les humanités merci
beaucoup à vous trois merci à très
bientôt
au revoir au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh